ん
うん
洞察から三共
どうですねすとお願いことがございますよ
単刀直入に言いますねはい一君
文字ロゴやてください
a
ホイッやってくださいアーケードください
ねこんな感じですねえええ
マジなんマジです
あんっああ
なるほど
1回やめっ
理解止めておりますよねそうですよねー
いやまぁそなるほどですね
へんよはいいいんじゃないでいいですよ
どうしたのどうしたの本当にヤバく ko
hi 話させてたんですそれでトレカのあ
これじゃあじゃあですじゃあ本当に彼を
説明しますと去年分去年の7月末で辞め
ますそうですね大地くん僕と一緒にその
働きフラベージュ
っていうグループチームだったり僕の裏方
として一緒に働いてたんですけども去年の
7月に家になりたいことがあるということ
でいつおうちの会社を始め株式会社を止め
ていたんですけども
どっさーん
さんほしいっまずハイあの辞めた理由を
あんまり詳しく話せて促しあるしいいのか
あってでまあ辞めたことにいろいろこ結婚
しましたとご報告させてもらったんです
けどそうそう以前それですねカーみつる顔
れるよね
まず一番やり方と事っていうのがですね
まずやっぱり結婚っていうのが生んだ位置
にあってそうだねでなぜ結婚したから止め
たといいますと
何でもなんかこう
youtube のどうか言って結婚し
たらこう
何だろう黒うまくやっていけないなって
いうのが頭にありました僕的にやっぱり
みんなもキー使うし特に一君と貨物を聞い
使うかなっていうのがすごい好きねぇ
たまにあってまあその奥さんもそうです像
可動もができるぞそうそうお父さんを全裸
でを取らせたりするのはぞ
しづらい部分あるかなぁですかその
いろんな方にこうやっていくのが難しい
かなっていう勝手な自分なうん憶測でもう
行動してしまったというのがまず大事に
あってそういった理由で辞めて正結婚させ
てもらって
であの一般企業の方にもう1本務めさせて
もらってすごいいい会社だねうんん
こんな僕でも売っ
受けてくれるしちゃっとこ仕事振ってくれ
たし
&やっぱりこうちゃんと叱ってくれるん
本当に何だろう
ねえ
本校
元に言い換えする本当にいいじゃなかった
言葉が詰まったでしょ
本当にか言うんだねっと本当にもっと言っ
チューブやっちゃいまーそうだとやってた
と関係なしに接してくるなぁとってもいい
会社だと思ったんですけどやっぱりこう
長年 youtube 言っ
やっぱ心のどこかに
youtube やりたいっていうのが出
てきてやっぱりこんなネーミン一君たのか
と畑もと畑のみんなと思うやってたのが
やっぱりどこかにあってチャミ今日からハ
時に戻りますでしょ
プロフェシーから6時間ほどらしい
なるほど今でもやっぱり結婚しちゃって
自分から辞めたうん自分から退いたていう
あったからなかなか来たりにも相談できる
ただそういった思いがいっぱいどんどん
大きくなってでまずはやはり奥さんうん
そうだね僕も独り身じゃなくなったんで
家族として奥さんに話して
まあこうこうこういうこと思ってるんだ
よっていう離して
そしてやっぱり
んん
自分奥さん的にあった自分のせいで今辞め
させてもらえばシャッシャッまあずっと
あっ新しくておかーやっぱそういうつもり
ではないのっていう自分の考えでやめたし
一般企業になっても後悔もしてなかっ
たっていうのも話で一般的なしますよ染め
たん求め何だろうねパパ本当にやりたい事
っていうのは何だろうっていうのをやっ
パターン
考えたの中で
やっぱ youtube の境界みんなと
またこれやりたいっていうのがずっと頭で
やってやっぱり
一般化したらみんなだからすると甘い考え
だっていうのはもちろん重々わかってるん
ですけども確かに本当にねじゃあうぇっ
集いたじゃんだって俺そうあの子栄で
メッツ止めたのがすごいってる恋のは本当
に覚えている一君そう
やめるって話した時にいうそれだったら
やっぱりこう裏方とか他にも道があるか
提案してくれたんだけどそのときには
やっぱり個分
自分の中ではもう破るのが第一のれないか
なっていうのが頭にあったので
なんか俺の
結婚もんだけどねこれは勝手にうん畑正
リーダーだったじゃねうん動脈でねその下
にみんなが入って上に俺が入ってからう
うーん板挟みの中間色エアー結構一番取材
かなと思っていないから言われたりする
さんねこれはそのつらさもあったのかなと
思ったん
リアルな話
逆にそこは特にうーんん6みって言うか
んったもちろん
悩むこともあったけどそこまで自分が一番
適任者だなみたいのがあったからドゥのは
そう特に
重みは感じてなかったんだけどももっと
そのやめるって言う時に結婚するっていう
時にもっとこうみんなと話してれば変わっ
たのかなっていうのもあったんですけど
もし気ねーちょっと
ギクシャクしてですがあったそうそうです
ねやはり自分がやりたいうち v まで
やりたいっていうのが大きくなって正源
くんとか他登壇してこれまず全然御連絡と
なくてもそうだけど忙しいけどがあのう
今言われたわけじゃないんですよね
ちょっとですねもちろん前々からずっとの
ない智くんが辞めたけど
とってきたいって話は聞いてたんですけど
ちょっと僕が装いずに忙しくて熱けどその
真面目になんで戻ってきたいのとかそう
いう話をする機会なくハンターなど続いて
6つかて取れの母ちゃんの花するそうです
私ですがセルゲームを戻っていくことに
なってるんですけど今本土この動画とって
改めて魔女に話してるっていう状況です
結果的にこう受けてもらったんだけど
たしかにただ良い会社だねちょっといい
会社が個人的にはよ経営者としては良い一
回辞めた会社に戻ってきてくれるとはじめ
株式会社めちゃいい
クロスいいかするから
俺的に汗だくです
と思っておりませ本当にそう他の畑の
みんなも話した時にはすごいものと聞いて
うれしい受け入れてくれてすごい
ありがたいんですけどただやっぱりこう
それ以上に迷惑かけた部分もやっぱりある
しもちろん
ほんとなんかにゃむずい
よし
やっぱり一君のこの今会社もそうだし
今で1年間
働かせてもらった会社にもやっぱりすごい
命をかけたん
確かに1年形でてる嫁だってくれそう本当
に鈴そうなんだっそうなんですよ笑い事
じゃない奴ほど本当にたくさん目をかけて
向こうの社長さんどうもすごい何回も話だ
し社長さんも本当に最初は止めたっていう
んもう少しちょっと考えてみたらって並べ
たんですけど
政治的にはやっぱり自分がやりたいことを
尊重してくれてなかなかないと思うんです
よねやまず戻ってきてくる
パーン
ことにやもどって来るだぜ俺はも嬉しい
ですよなんならもう一緒にずっとやり
たかった思うんだし嬉しいし
会社的にやっぱり今もいいんですけど
なーんか戻ってきたくない会社っていいっ
にマーレキャプチャいいんやでぃあーん
って
usatan 2分会社の経営塩的な部分
のブランディングにおいてはプラスの方面
が多いかなととうんち的に派手で大きな
メリットでわかるかなと思っておりますが
そうだねば畑がねぇ
[音楽]
大地くんという人間が大きかったから
チームとして大地くんがやっぱ抜けてから
ちょっと調子が悪くなったかなっ気
思っちゃってちょっと大地くんのねー
畑に置いてのわたり台車がかなりでかかっ
たなっていう
大竹のパワーを実感した
1年だった年
た移民をタイミングだったかとホント急な
ことでやめちゃってそれで何でもやっぱり
洋平君とか他の人たちも急に自分の仕事を
任せちゃうっていうのもあってとすごい
悩んでうんたり苦労したこともあったと
思うんですよ
そういった中でもあのもうとりたいて自分
のわがままも言った時にすごいなんだろう
嫌な顔せず
僕も持って来るのっ
本当になるかもしれないと思って
ねいやいいけど俺はいいんだけど
畑のみんながどうもそうだっていうのが俺
はちょっと不安かなと思っちゃうかな数本
名前でこんな普通3各社というのもなんだ
けど虫のいい話だって
んちゃんって辞めたいただいつしかないっ
て
みんなで止めてそれをしたいことがある
から送り出したけど帰ってきたということ
はうれしいのはもう当たり前なんだけど
やっぱり大地くんが見なくなってから
みんなすごい苦労したと思う突然戻って
くるとねやっぱ嬉しいんだけど
別の肝臓としてあそんな戻ってこれるんだ
みたいにやはりみんなが何かどこがまだか
まりができるっていうか小山田している
部分多分あると思うからうん
そこはちょっと
いきなりその前と同じように戻りますと
いうのは
ちょっと不公平だなって思っちゃうん部分
はあるかな
めっちゃ撮影でも話せないけどねほんとに
やんけど本当に大地くんの力ってすごい
以外になったからめっちゃ嬉しいです本当
に守られることはそういった部分も
もちろんあるの当然なしん
やっぱり見ている方からもしても
という同じようなことであいつ自分で止め
たのまた戻ってくるなんてあげようって
いう意見もあるのも本当重々承知
ですしあの守らせてもらってるからー
こそ何でも今まで以上にそれを払拭払拭と
いうか戻らせていただけるからこそなんか
今まで以上に本当に頑張って
一君に対してもやっぱり畑のみんなにも
で辞めた会社にとっても本当に認めて
もらえるぐらい後豆
あとにまた嫁にもいや俺はいいんだけどで
本当に何か皆をた嬉しいんにょを見てくれ
ていることは
けど正直彼のみんながやめて
同じように戻ってこれって思われるのは俺
はちょっとやら何でもちゃうぱねみんな
生活かけて
ユーチューバーそれっぽく見えますけど
チョコれ生活かかってますからね我々も
っていう感じかな
正直な観光は自分が止めてずっと戻ってき
てるまあ正直本当に皆どう思ってるん
だろうまあそう
そんな想いを裏切らないよ
それでももう一ずもおかえりって言って
くれるうん何
こうなんだろこ
その気持ちに応えるように
まあそうだね全力で畑とか始め株式会社の
でもサポートでき
させて頂けたらなんていうのはすごい
気持ちにあるので
そういった行動でやっぱ示していくしか
ないかにもある
確かに人一倍頑張ってくれそう
もちろん何でもやります
何でもやります版が皆さんからそれが本当
に大事に戻ってきて嬉しいって思ってるん
ですけど
思ってるんですかってパンザサッカー
みたいになったっていうけどうれしいと
思ってくださった方は本当に多いと思うん
ですけどもやはりですね組織とか会社って
いうものは誰にでも都合よくあってはいけ
ないというかんファンの皆さん嬉しいけど
実際やってるみんながその不変不満を抱い
ているグループに僕は絶対したくないと
思ってるんで掃除機せゲーその幅県の正規
メンバーに戻ります団みたいな感じ
じゃないとは思っちゃうやっぱ読めずに
頑張っているみんなのことを僕は評価し
たいですしかといってもその戻ってきて
くれた大地くんを評価してないって訳でも
ないから畑にわっ
たまにいきましょうはいわかりました卵
ジフン書庫教育が帰ってきています感動さ
れているファンの方も多いと思います何か
一言
人ほど
これから弾き込みが誰もぜひ込
そうだね
[音楽]
また河川デー
ブーブー運河年版の方はすごい家元で行っ
たら言われる押すんですけど
その以下6ですよなかねんにまた立裏方
やってよみーのアーサーの10月ぐらいが
止まっていくのがあるって言うなあ
ちょっとネバダ5君のねー人としての
柔らかさがすごかったりない地区見えなく
なってくる3つかたくなっちゃって皆様
いくんがすごい相談を受けたりと思うん
以上で坊舎って言うべくんそれはでなくだ
なという感じでいい
by 力を持っていきたいと入っでってき
てくれました本当に嬉しいまずありがとう
ございますありがとうございます嘘乗ると
1年間
そしてやめてしまって悲しいんだハンド方
もいらっしゃると思うんですけどはい行き
たいしておりますよろしくお願いします